My AST and ALT, these are liver enzymes, are elevated, and the pharmacist said it's like
they do to the gamma pental.
So what are things that could elevate your liver enzymes?
Well, if I have metastasis to my liver, my liver is going to be irritated, and that could
elevate my liver enzymes.
Oftentimes, first, if I can have metastasis to the liver, they don't even have elevated liver
enzymes.
If I had elevated liver enzymes, the first thing I would think of would not be metastasis,
I'd think of what's affecting my liver currently.
So even if you're like an ibuprofen, that could raise your liver enzymes.
It could be very irritating your liver.
Certainly, any prescription medication, if you're on chemotherapy, that could raise your
liver enzymes, anything like that that could overwhelm your liver, can raise your liver
enzymes.
It's really nice that you have an honest pharmacist.
And you can look up the drugs you're on, certainly do a Google search of the different medications
you're on and see the side effects of those drugs.
Problem is that the gamma pental is taken away 75% of my hot flashes, so my horrible blockers
that I could finally sleep, how concerned are these levels AST 53, ALT 92.
Well, again, it's like, it's hard to say that, you know, it was just saying that there's,
you know, I don't have to be worried about this.
There's not going to be that much damage to my liver at that.
These are markers, so these are markers that your liver is being taxed.
So, yeah, I mean, you've got to balance it all out a little bit.
Maybe just try to support your liver in different ways.
If you want to stay on the gamma pental because it's giving you a lot of relief, then maybe
just try to support your liver with doing more coffee enemas, doing more orchestral packs,
things like that for your liver.
Also, maybe talk to the pharmacist or the prescribed doctor about reducing the dosage of the drug.
Many people are surprised that if you take 75% or maybe even 50% or even only 25% of the
correct drug, you're on it or you, or you titrate down to that.
It still has the same effect.
It still has the same benefit, but it's less toxic to your body.
So consider those options.
You're on a lot of tumor or anything else, so we talked about that.
And you write programs, certainly the liver programs on the right, that's what I would look
at.
The normalizing frequency folder has programs for different organs, and you can look at the
liver programs in the normalizing frequency folder.